hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled auto antibodies as
biomarkers in immuno oncology this
webinar is a part of the fifth annual
drug discovery and development virtual
conference
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminex a diasoren company
for more information about luminex a
diasoren company go to
www.luminexcorp.com
[Music]
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker hans
dieterzook phd chief technical officer
oncommune germany gmbh for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen
hans theater you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you for your kind introduction
uh good morning or good afternoon uh
depending on where you are located
so today's talk will be covering a topic
about auto antibodies as biomarkers in
um immuno-oncology
and just let's clarify uh the notion of
auto antibodies or tumor-associated
antibodies is somehow
uh used in different domains and medical
science differently auto antibodies is
more uh used in the run methodology
field and and you all know cancer uh
two more associated antigens more in the
cancer field here
so it's actually
what are the expected uh developments
especially in
cancer research and the need for
biomarkers which we do see right now so
it's actually
we will have an increased demand in
safety studies
for cancer immunotherapies
as immunotherapies are moving to an
earlier stage in cancer treatment and
require wicked safety
monitoring and hopefully after these end
of the
corona pandemic so there will be a ramp
up a revival of clinical trials in
cancer
and
if we will also and that's actually what
to be expected are to address core
challenges in uh checkpoint inhibitory
therapy
which which are for example response
non-response topics or topics around
adverse reactions
we're facing currently and seeing a lot
of
studies going on trying to
to establish combination their
combination therapies cpi combinations
with other modalities and one element is
bifunctional antibodies
so b cells
so anybody in cancer usually we are
speaking about t cell biology so
actually i want to
break into the b cell
here also b cells play a role so it's
actually you have these immunomodulatory
aspects
b cells of course can also uh
support and and inhibit tumor
development we have um
as i mentioned already tumor associated
uh uh antibodies with nk cell
combination
and b cells are
promoting tumor development and
might explain response or non-response
phenomena
and switching to the next element is
actually what are auto antibodies or two
more associated antibodies bringing to
this equation in total and on the right
hand side you see
that antibodies participate in have so
many roles so they can
participate in this
biological processes by
blocking receptors or interacting with
receptors
by
attacking the cell of course and all in
all we will have and we have to consider
that the immune system is a fine balance
which is illustrated here with this
balance and this is also important to
recognize
that with the
use of cpi treatment and other
treatments which stimulate the immune
system
where the immune system is actually
treated
in the context of cancer that this
balance
is a balance which can
also go into some negative areas where
over stimulation
can be harmful or lead to
destruction of structures which are
essential and
in the physiology here
so
this is
a definitively one of the problematic uh
squares i would say immunotherapies work
but they are sometimes limited to a
minority of patients and it would be
really good to understand
how this can be extended
and how the non-responder rate
especially can be maybe
found out to
to
counter to be counted
and i mentioned already the activation
of autoreactivity is something which
also limits the application sometimes
and this these are the two application
fields which we want to address as a
biomarker company
looking into trials and looking into
patients what happens and what goes on
so other antibody production cancer is
a source of biomarkers so how does this
in this
sketch here you see how the antibodies
are actually appearing and this is
starting from the left side we have an
altered protein structure perhaps on the
surface
mutations and defective proteins are
exposed and the cell surface
over-expression
breakdown products and so forth
and these
malformed proteins can appear quite
early in the overall malign processes
and the immune system recognizes these
structures
and
has then the chance to produce
antibodies which are recognizing for
example
and starting recognizing this of these
rotational load perhaps
the nice thing
basically in investigating antibodies in
a blood sample is that serum and
antibodies are very stable it's a stable
analyte you can draw it easily
you don't need a tissue biopsy it's in
in essence a fairly simple so-called
liquid biopsy
and you can even buy dry it on a paper
disk
and then send it around and investigate
and serology
theological responses are really easy to
measure
with immunoassays and
with this if we were to to develop
models around this about response or
non-response or adverse reactions
then at the end of the day it is an easy
tool which can be easily deployed in
practice it does not need a mouse back
at the end you just need an instrument
you need an elisa or you can measure
this by using luminix instrumentation
and so forth
so um
how is this then
how do we do this and how do we deal
with autoimmunity auto antibodies tumor
as i said in antibodies so you need two
ingredients which you see on this slide
starting on the left hand side
so
one what you need of course is the
patients the patient's area with the
on the bottom left
from patients or studies and groups
and on the top left side you see that's
actually what we how do we do this we
have a set of proteins antigens on stock
which we produce recombinantly
or which we are procuring by buying them
or peptides which we synthesize and so
forth
so very large
antigen repository
and we are using luminex x-map
technology here we're coupling the
antigens which we have uh
two beats and we are
uh performing a beat-based
um immunoassay beat-based array that's
actually in the bottom it's in a
straightforward
direct
immunoassay here
and then
we are measuring and this is the
overall beauty of this system is
actually low volume consumption we can
deploy a lot of antigens
running a lot of samples this is fairly
fairly straightforward to set up and
and do the quality around this i will
come to this later and what we're doing
then is the
typical
match uh extraction of the informative
antigen targets we peel them we pull
them out of
like baits here if you want so
and we're then creating a feature
ranking looking which
which antigens are reacting to the serum
samples so you have the the illustration
is here the red color should guide you
through we have a red antigen and a red
antibody
together we're hoping that we identify
this novel target
and then in cancer for example we can
focus down and narrow down
and create models and and panels out of
these identified antibodies this is a
really superficial
nutshell here but you get the idea
so how how does this look in the
laboratory on the right hand side you
see instruments which are uh supported
here
flexima 3d we have several instruments
in our lab which are
supporting and giving the readout
and liquid handling robotics is needed
for
processing these samples and also
getting a good reputability all in all
the automation here is key
and on the left hand side you see in
principle how we do we couple the
antigens to the
color coded beads
from luminex here there are bearing
different labels of fluorescence and
coupling is done in separate vials
and then we can combine them because the
instrument as working like a flow
cytometer is able to
re-establish the
coordinate the beat number if you want
so to find out which antigen is reacting
with the theorem at the at the end and
this enables multiplexing in a very nice
way
so the benefit actually in using luminex
technology is uh and this is actually
here two data from
comparing
uh rapid repeatability of the measure we
have here measured on the left hand side
you see an essay which is related to
double strand dna
which we investigated and here we are
comparing data sets obtained in 2017
together which with data from 2021
and you get the idea so the
repeatability is very high
and also on the right hand side this is
actually a patient the technical full
technical replicat of a patient sample
is also illustrating that the
concordance and the repeatability of
these measurements is very high it is
and this is really an advantage
uh over technologies which for example
use slides also
here it is much harder to achieve
a high concordance in the low
coefficient of variation so
a technical aspect but this is an
important one
so at once moon we are not using only
libraries which are very common in
libraries so it's easy i mentioned
already that the coupling of the
antigens as baits to pull out the
antibodies and tumor associated
antibodies is often driven by ideas and
hypotheses
and you have to source those proteins
and we are sourcing them from
very broad so we have an own expression
library
here you see a full orthium library from
thermo fissure but we are also sourcing
antigens by buying and and
asking partners to synthesize peptides
in large amounts and large sets so this
is a interesting
uh in in many aspects but also uh
transfected cells and mammalian proteins
and so forth that's a large source
of proteins which we can deploy
and it depends on what we want to
investigate for example i will come to
this aspect later for example if we are
interested in organ specific toxicity
also
then one would uh assemble proteins
together and and putting them for
example out of the shelf to say i want
to have lung specific or brain specific
antigens or
to
investigate this particular aspect of
toxicity for example
so in any biomarker
work this funneling
is important and to recognize this is
basically a work which is true which
holds true for our
work which is done in microarray
expression studies mass back or alike so
it's actually you're starting usually
with a large number of and
of targets attributes
uh in in
discovery approaches
and then you'll have to uh after
your prioritization you will have to
write down what you found so the panels
and the arrays and
the hits if you want so write them down
and this is also what we do in repeated
studies and see here actually we're
using a branding for this for example
zero tag the we refer to the technology
which is at the edge of discovery
and then we're creating panels um uh
narrowing them down high content panels
[Music]
the amount of antigens we are measuring
in these high content panels is is 96
for example which is a good
which is a good fit to the one element
of
multiplexing
with the
xml technology which is then can be done
in a micro tighter plate and it's a very
convenient format
and then at the end of the day uh
narrowing it farther down depending on
how you want really to deploy be it an
elisa or
be it uh
that we will have to focus on only a few
markers
and and calibrate them and measuring
them in an essay this is actually this
funding goes
according to the rules of medical uh
device development product development
and
for these endpoints you then use all
this
regulatory requirements
design goal design inputs
and design control which are
key and the drill in this iso 13485
context where
when for example deployment as an essay
or as a medical device
is the endpoint
of everything
so how do these sets actually i think
the next slide gives you an idea about
how we assemble the panels we are
investigating and here this is one slide
one example
uh because we have to make choices here
uh the autoimmune panel is fueled what
we are using is field when we are
investigating autoimmunity
in
in its core it's more related to the uh
antigens which we know already which are
um
uh others say in in regulatory
guidelines etc etc so you have pathways
around cytokines chemokines interference
and so forth
and when aiming and uh towards the
immuno-oncology panel then there are
antigens included like tumor cancer
testis antigens for example are playing
an important role
but also there's also an overlap and you
see in and at the bottom here uh genes
which come for example from thyroidism
are very
popular right now because we do see that
they are
upon stimulation of the immune system
reactions against
thyroid thyroidia structures can happen
and and there you see there is an
overlap between this and this is also
where we came from that's actually
seeing
and learning are the different demands
from the fields and we are complementing
these antigens here
so here is one panel for example which
is
called sle
panel here it's just giving you the idea
how this looks like because this is what
was our starting point where we learned
to deal with patients and also on the
next slide gives you an idea about how
an auto antibody reactivity looks like
in a typical fashion enrollment
so and this is also true for cancer this
is very same
you have a prevalence which is which is
a number um
and a b modal distribution of the
reactivity so it's not every patient
having a positive reactivity here and
you have to deal with this it's not a
typical clinical chemical analyte which
goes which changes all in all
you have
always the positivity of patients
stepping up and
what
the bioinformatics people have to do are
actually scraping
from this top
edge the patients which are positive for
markers but also exploiting the
quantitative information around
so
in the next slide you see this is
basically when you are considering in
cancer on a cpi treatment for example
you see that different checkpoint
treatment regimes are affecting so they
are
causing different
organs organ problems which are involved
you see here in the different in color
on the left hand side rdpd1 ntcdl4
in pink here skin liver
lung perhaps then ctl4 you have a gi
involvement that's actually i will show
you later on some examples of data
um
that
for example colitis is an important
problem which can
appear but
um
it's different in the organ involvement
and on the next slide which we are now
seeing is actually how we design and
investigate this we're putting if you
want exactly
uh those proteins in the panels and and
looking for can we find something in
brain or in the third idea
and this is also here you can
if you have these and that's actually
what we're doing
add some of those targets which are
coming up frequently in our hands like
tpo tshr
or anti-insulin
type
so insulin
related antibodies and so forth and this
is the beauty actually the customization
of these
beat-based areas allows you
to include the antigen which you are
want to look at and to include in your
models
so i will just um
pull a few slides for studies which you
have done to to learn and investigate
one by one
here one um
observational study which we've done
with the
national
cancer center in heidelberg
with
professor jessica hussell and actually
she was supporting us and
we were able to access samples
you see these characteristics from
melanoma
samples here it was the question was
basically to find out
um
what
pauses or what reasons can be linked to
the
appearance of adverse immune related
adverse reactions and we focus in the
beginning very much
on colitis
we were said okay this is one of the key
problems we have here and as you see
here the combination
we wanted to find out what are overlaps
what are distinct patterns for example
for anti-cdlr4 or rtpd-1
therapeutic
points and this is basically how i ex so
we did this exactly what i explained you
before we used our immune oncology
discovery panel and tried to to map the
um
ire
response behavior to potential antibody
candidates
so what we found out was basically that
exactly you see here this is on the
right hand side very tiny but
[Music]
it's a partially squares regression
which is a bioinformatics pattern
where you uh can look into the uh
all overall multivariate dependency of
biomarkers which are here the black dots
and the uh um
so the related clinical variables which
are in red
and the black um commands here give you
the idea so it's actually what we've
seen in the study
uh really roughly that there is some
variance in the data which is related to
poor outcome on one but also um
which goes together with a
fewer uh immune related adverse event
and on the other hand side you have
these it's actually a better outcome
with more ires
and it seems to be that we are seeing
here in this projection um
and uh there actually this balance
between perhaps between stimulation and
suppression this is
in perhaps naive but this is what we
were kind of expecting
and we were seeing exactly that and the
markers related to this here you see
them
in names
some go down some go up and we are and
this is basically important to
we are doing the other antibody
interpretation also from the perspective
of the respective involved gene or
protein target
and try to find out do we understand the
proteins or what is already published
and
in pathway interpretations
and it is important to
remind ourselves that these antibodies
which are appearing are in many cases
can participate in
are in the metabolism which has been
shown also recently if you look into the
pandemic results antibodies against
cytokines interference and so forth
and many occasions in many occasions
they are neutralizing and participating
so this gives us perhaps ideas
around why they're appearing or what
happens here
and um
the pathways make sense
and the hazards ratios here so the
univariate statistics then at the end
give you the hazard ratio so it's
possible to look into the individual
markers and say okay there are perhaps
situation markers which are protective
and others which are more
stimulating uh here i want to feature
two which one was this
mitf i think i have a slight later on
this and also gastrin releasing peptide
which might be
hard to say
um a link which
makes sense in in terms of colitis or so
perhaps that some target which is
somehow located or regulating uh gusman
intestinal functions
is important
so what do it's besides those typical
also here you see for example cancer
testis antigens
mage
the mages they are very popular
in cancer immunity but what we also see
is often then there are antibodies
against cytokines and this is basically
here in this small sketch you see okay
uh there are this is a nordic slide if
you say to split between pro-tumor and
anti-tumor
cytokines and
signaling molecules
and this is basically our current
um
[Music]
so what we see
frequently in our data that
anti-cytokine
antibodies appearing appearing and
frequently appearing and which keeps us
interested which makes us interested in
those
to find out can we really invest learn
from this more so what does this really
mean in terms of survival perhaps or
what does this mean and in terms of
regulating biology because this is
basically an acquired property
see here one example uh from this
melanoma study where you see
survival can be linked
if you split the values for certain
antibodies against
those molecules into high and low
and stratify the patients accordingly
and this is just first data here but we
are looking into this deeper and are
interested also to find out what
what we can learn further on
is this is a common topic here like this
what you see in the middle or uh like 18
or so that survivor can might be
linked to those antibodies this keeps us
interested and enthusiastic
which i mentioned already here you see
the split if you spread stratify
patience
anti-mitf antibodies are related to
colitis
uh this is basically how we do see this
uh for the
event for the time to event onset of
iras and melanoma patients and
where we see
[Music]
we can link it together
okay so ngrp i mentioned already
a gastrointestinal peptide also making a
difference between
patient groups
so the uh so the actually um measuring
cytokines and
anti-cytokine antibodies is one the
second application area where
our auto antibody and um
tumor associated antibody measurement
max sensor keeps us interested is
actually in the investigation of
vaccination response
so we did this here so you see here
vaccination transient in the study which
we've
got from where we got patients from the
national cancer institute
and these are samples from
prostate cancer patients mrc rpc a study
with
prosthetic and prosthetic in combination
with
immunostimulating immuno checkpoint
inhibitor here in combination
i just want to bring this here uh narrow
this here that we do see and this is
nicely uh can be nicely measured and
observed individual patients are
connected with lines you see transients
after vaccination and this is then in
this context an application which can
investigate are the differences in the
amount
of the immune response and the answers
yes we can see some differences here but
we can also see and
look into the
timing and transients and on the next
slide i i completely skip into a
different realm but very similarly this
is actually how vaccination
after uh kovitz looks like very similar
yeah you have these
onsite you can learn what is the timing
and what's the decay are here in this
case and this is actually
where the individual uh serial multiplex
zero logical uh technology works quite
nicely for prostate back to prostate
cancer what was making us or keeping us
interested is
i mentioned already cytokines but this
is not only a
reaction against cytokines and receptors
but it could also happen that antibodies
are forming
which are against
essential enzymes
i don't know how this really works out
how this
is forming and presented but this is
actually an example
we had in this prostate cancer study uh
linked to survival
basically a hit which was
linked to anti-idol which was in our
interest list on number one
and of course you can
debate about okay can it circulate is it
exposed and and and
and but it is interesting for us to
recognize that
these measurements can identify
interesting not only diagnostic targets
perhaps but also applications where you
say okay we can learn something about
the metabolism from that
in this slide
plc which was i think it was a few days
ago uh presented from uruzil carcinoma
receiving immune checkpoint inhibitors
investigation which we've done together
with the donor father institute
and actually seeing that also here again
that auto antibody can be investigated
for the progression
and
creating models out of this and a
single example this is also from the
same study here i mentioned the
thyroidia
biology and here you see for example
that a pre-treatment and the
post-treatment sample here this is two
dots just
popping up so the majority of
serological responses of of this patient
of this very patient
stays more or less the same it's here on
this
on
on a 45 degrees
scatter plot but you see popping out the
tpu and tshr which are
which is reactivity against um
thyroidia hormones which are essential
and this is basically what we want to
investigate and see
is is there something going on which uh
keeps our attention
okay this is
all uh it's the summary slide is the
next slide you see here actually hope
um you've seen and learned from the uh
presentation when i
summarize this beatbase multiplex
protein arrays
this is basically for the application of
finding novel
auto antibody targets but also for
assembling
panels uh and uh
investigating and this is actually
multiplexing low serum conduct
consumption will can be deployed and
used if you want to as an analytical
swiss knife and tool
and
the nice thing is actually the that it
can be deployed by anybody
then
discovery studies yield interesting
targets and biology this is basically
what you've seen
and there are detectable
so this is actually what we are starting
we are starting with baseline samples
basically so of course what is baseline
in this case is pre-treatment and of
course pre-treatment samples have
already uh they underwent already the
disease
mechanism and everything that's actually
baseline here
and then
from that perspective later on we are
able to investigate
and
we can see
antibodies appearing with favorable or
non favorable outcomes
and
this is basically
where we want to learn and further
narrow down
interesting
[Music]
targets here and last but not least
vaccination transients
seems to be easy but this is actually
interesting anybody who has really
combining
can also investigate if there anything
hits beyond that
very protein which is probably injected
or so because in certain locations it
happens that the suction vaccination
transients are
broader than expected and this is an
interesting aspect
okay so thank you for your
attendance
and this is was my talk
thank you hans dieter for your
informative presentation
we will now start the
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started
our first question is
how can auto antibody biomarker findings
be developed further
yeah this is um the answer to this
question is uh i i think i covered it
uh kind of because basically when you
have the name which is like uh like a
passport number you have a recipe and
the recipe is basically setting up
an elisa or an essay at your hand and
and this is one element of course and
the second is with this recipe so it's
applicable in the field it does not
need a complex instrument but of course
also from the perspective of
investigating biology around searching
around is giving you an idea
where you can look at and if this fits
to your ideas and hypotheses which you
have
great thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
what is the link between an auto
antibody and the biological role of the
protein target
yeah sometimes it's
sometimes confusing because actually
when you're talking about a certain
target's name
it is confusing that we are talking
about anti yeah so it's actually
um
uh one has to be very clear that an
antibody against il whatever il-10 is
something and al-10
can be matched together but it just has
been somehow we are
in ourselves in the laboratory
forgotting this forgetting this but it's
really important that we're talking
about some a principle against a certain
target
great
actually we have time for one last
question um how are the baseline samples
detected in an immunocompromised
individual
um
so basically so it's actually uh we're
starting pre-treatment here this is uh
what baseline uh mentions but also uh
the question
of immunocompromi compromisation is this
correctly spelled is actually something
which effects then uh with which which
you can see if you just want to build a
classifier between of course you do see
differences here so baseline means
before treatment then
or
otherwise of course you need the correct
comparison group for getting an idea
about
what was going on in this particular
situation and it can for example if
you're depleting b cells or or then you
definitely see that something is
changing and then there are differences
great
well thank you hans theater do you have
any final comments for our audience
no thanks for having me uh was a
pleasure hope it was useful
thank you yes well thank you again hans
theatre for your time today and your
important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsors
luminex a diasoren company for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until february 2024
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye